(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Hey.
- [Kelly] Thank you for being here.
- Thank you for having me back,
I had such a great time last time.
- I was excited to have you back,
but then I was more excited
because I know you're friends with Jessie,
so we were like "Wait, we know you sing,
"do you wanna sing on the show?"
And then you said, "Yes."
- Of course I wanted to sing.
- I know, I was very excited.
Have you ever sang that song?
I hadn't.
- I've never sang that song.
No, I think I'd heard it before.
I mean, I'm sure I've heard it in a movie
or something like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I wasn't familiar with it.
And I love Sinatra,
I'm familiar with a lot of his stuff.
- Yeah, we were talking about
how you love his catalog.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's great.
- Me too, me too.
It is a weird song that a father
and daughter sing together.
- It's super creepy.
- Yeah.
It's very creepy that a father
and daughter are singing like,
"Yeah, I just wanna hang
out with you and I love you.
"We're gonna have drinks together."
- [Kelly] (laughs) Yeah.
- It's like, "Okay, bro."
- [Kelly] It's a little inappropriate.
- Calm down.
- But I love the song,
and I just let it go.
So, have you ever thought
of doing an album?
- I have, yeah.
I-
- 'Cause I want you to do,
I told him my goal for him, for me,
is to be in some kind of Rat Pack movie,
or if they redo "White Christmas."
We were talking about
that with Jessie earlier.
- Yeah, yeah, I would love to do that.
Listen, I-
- You have the perfect voice for that.
- Thank you, I really appreciate that.
- Yeah.
- I love singing so much.
I've gotten to do Broadway a couple times,
like I've told you,
but that's a very
Broadway type of singing,
and I would love to do
stuff that's more mainstream
or whatever it is.
- Yeah.
- Even if it's like Rat Packy,
that kind of an era,
all that stuff is golden to me,
just a bunch of bangers.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
I'm just saying,
you and Michael Bublé,
and me and Jessie,
getting to do, "White
Christmas," all over again.
- Oh my God, me and Bublé,
- [Kelly] What?
What?
- and you and Jessie?
- What?
- Come on.
- I think this is a great idea.
- Let's call up Bublé immediately.
- I was just like
"Wait, this would be
a really great movie."
Anyway, throwing it out there.
(Zachary laughing)
So St. Patrick's Day is tomorrow,
do you celebrate?
Do you get into that?
- I do, I have a lot of Irish blood in me.
- I do too.
- Any the Irish people in the audience?
(audience cheering)
- Me.
- All right, good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Get that Irish blood, yeah.
- I found out, 27%, 23andMe, thank you.
- Did you know you were
Irish at all before that?
- I did, I did, yes, yes.
- [Zachary] Okay, okay, yeah.
- But I didn't know the percentage.
- [Zachary] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So we have a good bit of
Irish in my family blood,
and my grandma was super
into St. Patrick's Day.
We grew up in Ventura, California,
and every St. Patrick's Day
there's a St. Patrick's Day parade.
- Yeah.
- And my grandmother was a part
of the Irish-American club,
and I don't know why or how
they got their hands on this,
but they had a float,
and that float was like
a big truck flatbed,
and they had this massive
inflatable green pig.
And I don't know why. (laughs)
I don't know if there's a pig
that's associated with St.
Patrick or Ireland at all.
- I feel it's the little
Lucky Charm kinda guy,
not a pig.
Wait-
- Well, yeah, that could be a leprechaun.
- Yeah, leprechaun, leprechaun.
- An inflatable leprechaun
would've made a lot more sense.
But they have a giant inflatable pig,
and it's green.
(Kelly laughing)
So they got it and they
put it on a flatbed,
and then we would just ride it down-
- They were like "This is free."
- Totally, exactly.
Hey, you guys want a green pig?
Yeah, anything green, it's fine.
And so, yeah, we would ride along
with that float every year.
When I was really cool I
roller bladed next to it.
- Oh my God, you were one of those guys.
- I was one of those kids.
- Don't worry about it.
- Totally, yeah, yeah.
All the way down the parade route too.
- I was too.
(both laughing)
Total nerd.
- Yeah, yeah, totally.
Yeah, so that was,
a lot of fun memories
with the family that way.
- That's so cool.
All right.
Well last time we were here
we talked about your move to Texas,
how's that going?
- It's good.
- 'Cause you're doing a whole
musical thing there, right?
- I'm trying to build a campus, yeah.
I'm trying to build
multiple campuses really
kind of around the country where
basically places where artists,
arts and the people who work in the arts
and sciences of entertainment
have a place to work and
live and play together,
and kind of create together,
and build a better life for
as many of us as possible.
- Networking.
- Yeah.
And in Austin, it's such a groovy town,
I mean I'm sure you spent
plenty of time there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Very music centric,
and so I think a music campus there
would be really awesome.
- Yeah.
- Amphitheaters to play music in,
and also recording
facilities to make music in,
and then a bunch of places for all of us
to live while you're doing it.
'Cause often times, don't you guys go,
you got to a specific place,
I know various artists will go
down to a Caribbean Island,
and go record an entire album
in that mindset.
You go to some retreat
or something like that.
- I think No Doubt did that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They did a Caribbean Island-
- The Joe Bros did too I'm pretty sure.
- [Kelly] Rocky steady or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ryan Tedder, he does
that stuff all the time.
- Yeah.
I just go to my closet in my house.
(both laughing)
- You're like I don't need it, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
- I'll take this staycation.
I can be inspired anywhere.
- Yeah, yeah, totally.
- It is nice though to have,
whenever I do go to a studio I like,
I like for the place to feel vibey.
And so what you're
creating does inspire you.
- Yeha, yeah.
- And it's also really cool
because a lot of people that are creative
don't know how to get started,
or don't know, they don't
know people to meet up,
the guitarist or the vocalists,
or whatever, writers.
And that's a really cool place.
You can do it in Atlanta, Texas.
- That's the thing.
And if you can bring people together,
I mean it's almost like,
not that I lived then,
but the village in New York in the 60's,
it was just nothing but artists,
and everybody was kind of
living next to each other
or on top of each other,
and poets would bump into other writers
or directors or actors,
and musicians.
- How many great things came from that.
- There was synergy, exactly.
And it just happened naturally,
and that's the kind of enviornment
I wanna create for sure.
- I love that.
So will you be using your new studio
to work on the "Chuck" reboot?
Because we heard the reboot
might happen, like a movie?
- Listen, did you guys want more "Chuck?"
(audience cheering)
- What?
What?
- I know, right?
Look at that baby.
Just a baby.
- I know, but it's so cool.
I mean it's such a cult following.
- Yeah.
- Chuck, I mean,
I'm telling you-
- I know.
- People in masses would
come to see this movie.
- Listen, I've been trying for years.
I was trying to make a "Chuck" movie
even before we finished
making the TV show.
It's getting closer-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm getting closer.
- Don't let us down.
(both laughing)
- The pressure.
Look, Josh Schwartz and Chris Fedak,
who are the writer and
creator of the show,
they're on board, I just
gotta get the powers that be,
meaning the folks at Warner Brothers
television and film to kind of help
let's put this thing together,
but all the cast is all ready to go.
Everybody's ready to go,
we just need a script,
and we need the money,
and the green light.
- Yeah, you need backing for it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Here's the thing though,
you have leverage 'cause we all want it.
So do it.
- So do it.
(Kelly laughing)
You heard it.
Kelly said do it, so we'll do it.
(audience applauding)
- Everyone is excited
that "Shazam" is back,
so was it fun to kind of
get in superhero mode again?
- Oh, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I mean it's such an
incredible gift of a job.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- Ever since I was a little kid
I dreamt about being an actor,
and I get to do that,
and that just blows my mind still.
And I also always dreamt
about being a superhero,
I think we all do-
- Yeah.
- When we're kids,
and I never really let go of that.
(Kelly laughing)
But the cool thing is I
love Tom Hanks in "Big,"
and I loved Christopher
Reeves in "Superman,"
and I get to play the lovechild of both.
- What a great, yeah.
- It really is.
It's "Big" meets "Superman,"
and it's so fun,
and I just get to tap into my inner child
that I never really grew out of
on a daily basis,
and just bring that to life.
And the fact that I got to do that once
was already incredible,
now I get to do it again,
and we get to bring the whole family,
the whole Shazamily back together.
All the rest of the cast.
- I love that, sharing of the,
I'm not ruining it, watch
the first one, spoiler alert,
but you share the powers.
I think that that's such a great lesson.
- [Zachary] Yeah.
- It's such a great message overall.
And also in this new one you
get to body slam Helen Miren.
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Yeah.
Let me tell you guys-
- [Kelly] A dame.
You got to body slam a dame.
- Yeah, I get to suplex
a dame into concrete.
- It's a big fight.
- Oh, it's so dope.
(audience laughing)
This scene, that scene
right there is so fun,
that was the first scene
we got to work together on.
It was like three pages of
us just having dialogue,
and I was so like "What am I doing?
"This is Dame Helen Miren right now."
And she's-
- Right after that
everything goes to hell.
- And then everything goes super south,
yeah, goes super south.
But she's the coolest.
I think she, yeah, she's
the undamiest dame,
she doesn't throw it around.
She's just like a really chill human
who wants to roll up her sleeves,
and jump in the sandbox and have fun,
and that's the kind of actor
you wanna work with always.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
And she's an icon on top of that.
- I already loved her,
but now I love her more
from that knowledge.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- And she, this fight is incredible.
- Yeah.
- So you also, amongst all your jobs,
had time to publish a book last year.
- I did, yeah.
- So it's called "Radical Love
Learning to Accept Yourself and Others."
This is so important, can I tell you why?
- Yeah.
- Because I read a bit,
and I think it's, for me to have a six
and eight year old kid, right,
and they go through things
like bullying at school, whatever,
things that happen,
learning disability, things like that,
and they can struggle, right?
When they see someone
that's a superhero to them
owning that life can be hard
and a struggle for even Shazam-
- Yeah.
- You don't know how cool that is for...
And I'm trying not to cry,
but you don't know how cool that is.
I was talking to Anthony Macky
about this the other day.
It's so cool that you all
are superheros to these kids,
but then you own things publicly
that are vulnerable things
that you don't have to,
you don't have to share,
but it's so cool that you do
'cause it makes them feel normal,
and it makes them feel
like they have a voice.
You know what I'm saying?
- I do.
- I don't know if you're
doing it for that reason,
and I'm not crying.
- We're not crying, we're not crying.
- Ignore this.
Allergies.
Anyway, it's just really important
to sit there with your kids,
and be like just so you know,
this guy struggles too.
You said you had such a
hard say the other day.
He struggles too,
and he's got a whole book about it.
And it really does make
a difference to kids
that you're their hero,
looking up to them,
that you're honest about that.
- I receive that.
I really receive that.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's so cool.
(audience applauding)
- But-
- 'Cause it's very vulnerable
like what you talk about.
- Yeah, but I think, I really do believe,
and I've said this many times before,
vulnerability is a superpower.
The more we can all allow
ourselves to be seen,
the more you are cuing other people
it's okay to be seen.
- Yeah.
- And then it's a ripple effect.
And opening and being honest,
and being transparent, it's
a really beautiful thing
because we're all wearing
so many masks we don't even realize
how often we're not being our
truest most authentic self
because we're trying to survive.
And society has all these conditions.
In middle school this horribleness
starts with being cool,
finding a click, being
accepted by the cool kids,
or whatever the heck that means.
I wish I could go back,
and shake my young self,
and say don't think about that,
don't worry about that,
go do your studies-
- You're gonna peak in high school.
- Yes, exactly, don't peek in high school,
bad place to be.
(Kelly laughing)
listen, I mean I basically,
the book gets into it,
but about six years ago,
when I made my move out to Austin,
I had this complete mental breakdown,
I didn't wanna live anymore,
and I didn't know why.
And thank God I had family
and friends around me
that were supporting me,
I got myself into this
life-saving therapy.
And after, I was still doing this therapy,
I was finishing it up
when I got the audition for
another role in "Shazam."
I sent my tape in, they liked it so much
they said "Hey, actually
he could be Shazam,
"we haven't casted that yet."
Then they auditioned me for Shazam,
and then I got the part.
All that happened in like one week
after having this breakthrough,
finally recognizing that I
never loved myself before.
- Yeah.
- And I had this breakthrough,
I was like "Oh my God,
I need to love myself."
Oh, now I'm gonna cry.
And so all of a sudden-
- 'Cause you're not
really able to love others
until you can love yourself.
- You can't, you can't, you can't.
Not fully.
We can do bits of that-
- [Kelly] Play the role.
- But if you wanna fully
completely love people,
the more kind you are with yourself
the kinder you can be with others.
The more patient you are with yourself
the more patient you can be with others.
And so I learned these things.
And then on the heels of
that I booked this job,
and because of that I felt,
I know I don't have to do this,
but I actually do.
I need to tell people
the only reason I got
to wear this super suit,
I literally went from
suicide to superhero,
and it was all because I learned
that I'm allowed to love myself,
and I'm worthy of that love,
and we are all worthy of that love.
(audience applauding)
- Worth is such a hard thing for so many.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Especially if you didn't
learn that at a younger age
and it carries over.
- And if I could have
gotten out of my own way,
and been practicing a
lot more true gratitude
for what I had and where I had been,
and by the way that
all, again, starts with
you have to love the life that you have.
You have to know that
you are worth loving,
even if you haven't accomplished
all the things you think
you're supposed to accomplish
in this world.
That will never get you there.
External validation does not provide that,
that has to come from within.
And so all of that external validation
that I had counted on, like this job,
being an actor and getting hired,
and being able to play that role
or this role or whatever,
no matter, it would bougie
me for a little while,
but then it eventually tapers off.
So you can't depend on that.
You've got to recognize
that it's spending time with yourself,
loving yourself, all these
things that I didn't understand
when I was in Austin,
and so it just spiraled.
I just went all the way down,
I felt like a complete failure,
and I needed people around me
to remind me that I wasn't,
but that I do think that the irony is that
when you do the work the
success actually comes
even more easily because
now you're prepared.
- You're almost open and inviting it in.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And I really do believe in that adage
God doesn't give you
more than you can handle,
the universe doesn't give
you more than you can handle.
- Sometimes I have arguments
with God about that.
(Zachary laughing)
- Sure, but you're still here.
- I'm like are you sure?
- You're still here,
and you're still alive.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're bringing joy to so many people.
- Yeah.
- I think that, yes, I'm with you,
sometimes you're like
I don't think I can handle this right now.
- Yeah.
- But what seemed like a
mountain turns into a mole hill
in the distance-
- [Kelly] Hindsight.
- You're like I did handle
it, I did handle it.
- I love you and I love you-
- I love you.
- for doing this book.
(Zachary laughing)
And helping people with
what you've learned,
and sharing that knowledge
'cause not everybody
is capable of going where you went,
and having those therapies.
Not everybody can afford
all that kind of stuff.
- Exactly.
- It's awesome to have
all that for people.
Let's do another break.
Zachary's book is called "Radical Love
Learning to Accept Yourself and Others,"
it's out now.
And "Shazam Fury of the Gods"
is in theaters tomorrow,
you have to go see it, it's so good.